بعد حوالي 8 ساعات على مدار يومين انتهت
شهاده الامير هاري التاريخيه امام المحكمه
العليا في لندن في الدعوه لرافعها هو
وتسعه وتسعين مشهور اخر على شركه ام جي ان
الاعلاميه اللي بتصدر
صحفهموا الشركه انها اخترقت هواتفهم ونشرت
معلومات عنهم حصلت عليها بطرق غير قانونيه
امس كان الامير هاري خلال شهادته عن تاثير
الصحافه الصفراء في حياته انه هو طول عمره
كان بيشعر انه يعني انه الصحافه بتنتهك
خصوصيته انه الصحافه الصفراء مضايقته
وتطفلها كان انه دور كبير في تخليه عن
واجباته الملكيه وتكلم كمان الامير هاري
عن دور الصحافه في حياه والدته الراحله
الاميره ديانا في الجزء الثاني من الشهاده
اليوم وكما كان متوقعا شهادته جابت سيره
افراد العيله المالكه والكلام اليوم كان
على اخوه اللي مو اول مره هاري بيهاجمه او
بيجيب سيرته بتصريحات خلي نقول انها مو
ايجابيه يعني هاني اليوم في المحكمه قال
عن اخوه الامير ويليام اللي هو امير ويلز
وولي عهد بريطانيا قال انه اندفع له مليون
جنيه استرليني في 2020 مقابل اسقاط قضيه
كان رافعها ضد وسيله اعلام اخترقت هاتفه
وعلى فكره هذه مو اول مره هاري بيتكلم عن
هذه التسويه السنه الماضيه وفي قضيه اخرى
جاب سيرتها ايضا لكن اليوم ولاول مره ذكر
المبلغ مليون باوند خلال الجلسه اليوم
الحوار بين الامير ومحامي الشركه كان
محتدم وان سمع المحامي وهو بيقول للامير
انا هنا علشان اسالك مو انت تسالني كان
مفاجئ في جلسه اليوم كمان رد الامير لما
ننسال لو عنده ادله على ادعاءاته باختراق
هاتفه فقال انه ما عنده لكن اللي كان ينشر
او اللي كان ينشر كان كلام مسجل برسائل
صوتيه على تلفونه وما في طريقه ثانيه
ينعرف فيها وقال ان هو رفع الدعوه علشان
يثبت تعرضه للاختراق
في ختام شهاده الامير سالوا محامي عن
احساسه وهو بيمر بكل اللي صار امام كل
اعلام العالم من بعد كده لحظات صمت ردها
للتاثر بانه كان احساس صعب
بالحديث عن الامير هاري والقضايا فهذه
القضيه في بريطانيا مو الوحيده المتعلقه
بالامير واللي بينظر فيها اليوم في العالم
فعلى بعد الاف الكيلود مترات وفي امريكا
مكان اقامته تنظر محكمه امريكيه اليوم في
دعوه رفعتها جمعيه محافظه بالطالب انها
تعرف كيف حصل الامير على تاشيره لدخول
البلاد وهو معترف من قبل اكثر من مره انه
اخذ مخدرات طبعا اشهر واكثر مره تكلم في
الموضوع كان في كتابه وعلى فكره اصلا معظم
الاشياء اللي قالها في المحاكمه وبيتحدث
لاحقا عنها انها غير مريحه بالنسبه للحديث
عنها مذكوره في كتابه في سبير على العموم
خلينا نقول انه نكمل مع بعض انه طالبت
المؤسسات الحكوميه بالكشف كيف حصل الامير
على التاشيره وطالبت كمان بالاطلاع على
الاستبيان اللي ملقوا الامير اللي يدخل
البلاد واللي فيه سؤال عما اذا كان الشخص
سبق وضعت المخدرات او لا
[موسيقى]